-Feels heavy.
-It might be heavy.
-Feels heavy. Ooh, okay.
-Alright.
-That's a little secret hint.
-Or was I acting?
-Or were you acting?
-Huh.
♪♪
Hmm.
-[ Whistling ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Okay.
[ Box clatters ]
[ Laughter ]
Do you know what's in my box?
♪♪
-I'm here with Channing Tatum,
and we are about to play
"Box of Lies."
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us have seen before.
Now, taking turns, Channing
and I are going to select a box
and open it
on our side of the table
out of view
from the other person.
Once the object
is out of the box,
you look at your opponent
and tell them what's in the box
You might be lying.
You might be telling the truth.
Your opponent has to guess
which one and say either lie
or truth.
If you guess correctly,
you get a point.
If you guess wrong,
the other person gets a point.
First to two points wins.
Channing,
you're the first male guest
to ever play this game.
Why don't you pick
the first box?
-Thank you, Jimmy.
-You're welcome.
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
-Mm. Mm.
Mm, dos. Oh, man.
Whoa, don't --
Oh! The third box.
Ooh, okay, ooh. Feels --
Feels heavy.
-It might be heavy.
-Feels heavy. Ooh, okay.
-Alright.
-That's a little secret hint.
-Or was I acting?
-Or were you acting?
-Huh.
♪♪
Hmm.
-[ Whistling ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Okay.
[ Box clatters ]
[ Laughter ]
Do you know what's in my box?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This isn't -- This isn't time
to plug your website.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, it is.
-I know what's in --
What is it? What is it?
What is it? What?
Let me see it. Let me see.
Let me see what you think --
You think you can play me?
You think you want
to get in this?
Want to get in this messy jungle
of a brain?
You want to get in
these eyes, huh?
Huh? You want to connect?
Like two LEGOs.
-Well, Jimmy...
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-What is in my box is...
a bowl of chili
frozen in gelatin.
[ Laughter ]
-A bowl of chili
frozen in gelatin.
Frozen chili?
Frozen -- Can't freeze gelatin.
[ Laughter ]
You lie!
Am I right?
-You are right.
-Whoa! What was it?
♪♪
Oh, my God. Is that Chewbacca?
[ Laughter ]
Frozen in gelatin.
-It is frozen in gelatin.
Alright, good.
It's like a Han Solo --
Alright, which one?
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
Someone said 10.
There aren't 10 boxes.
2, alright, here we go.
Ah, that's funny.
It's the one you were gonna take
when we first started the game.
♪ It's so light, it's so light ♪
♪ It's like feathers,
it's so light ♪
♪ It's so light, it's so light ♪
♪ It's like feathers,
it's so light ♪
[ Vocalizing ]
♪ Along ♪
[ Vocalizing indistinctly ]
[ Laughter ]
Don't try to look at my box.
-What is on your box?
-[ Chuckles ] Not "on" my box.
-Not on the box, this is --
-What is up your box?
-This is --
In. What was in my box.
-What -- What --
-Now it's out.
-It's out of the box?
-This is out of the box.
-It 'tis out of the box.
-'Twas in.
-'Twas now out.
-Now it's out.
What -- What's in my box
is, um --
It's a --
[ Laughter ]
It's a sugar cube
attached to a tea thread,
like, those little --
I don't know what you call that.
So it's like a tea --
Like a tea bag thread --
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not getting a clear picture
here of what --
-Connected to a sugar cube,
and at the end
of that tea bag thread,
instead of a little Lipton tag,
it's a sticker.
-What is on the sticker?
-It says, "Lick me
or legalize it."
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-Lies!
-That is the truth. It is a lie.
♪♪
Hot water bottle thing.
How did you know that? Alright.
Whoever wins the next one
wins the whole game,
Channing Tatum.
[ Giggles ]
-Alright.
-Oh! 4!
[ Audience shouting numbers ]
♪♪
I can tell you were struggling
to put that down.
It must be very heavy.
-Did you see --
Did you see the veins
popping out?
-You were like --
-I was like, "Ah."
-[ Grunting ]
♪♪
-[ Clears throat ] Mm.
[ Snorts ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Clears throat ]
Would you like to know
what's in my box?
-What is in your box?
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
-E.T.
phones home
in a sleeping bag.
[ Laughter ]
With crowns on it.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-E.T. is in the process
of phoning home
while he's in a sleeping bag
with crowns?
-Crowns on it.
-With crowns on it.
-Mm-hmm.
-E.T. phoning home
in a sleeping bag
with crowns on it.
♪♪
You lie.
[ Laughter ]
No!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The winner right there!
Channing Tatum!
Julia and I are about to face
off in a game of "Box of Lies."
All right, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects no one
has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick up a box,
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth.
We'll play three rounds.
Julia, why don't
you pick the first box.
-Why, thank you very much.
I shall.
-You're welcome. Yes.
Oh, 4.
-Okay. I don't know.
-The game has already begun.
-I'm very excited.
-It looks medium weight.
You didn't struggle, really,
carrying it over,
so it's not heavy.
All right. Okay.
-Okay.
-Don't cheat.
-I'm not cheating at all.
I feel like
you're cheating already.
-I'm not cheating.
-Yeah, well, you were,
like, confused at first,
and then you're amused.
-You're starting to irritate me.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, so...
Let me explain something to you.
-Yeah.
-You're familiar with something
that's -- A closet, right?
A closet?
-Yeah. Am I familiar
with a closet?
Yeah, sure.
I've never heard of that.
What does that word mean?
-Hang on, hang on.
And in this closet,
which is miniature, obviously,
there is a horse.
-Okay.
-And it has a huge collection --
Who thinks these up, by the way?
-Well, right now, I think
you're thinking this up.
-You don't know
what I'm about to say.
A huge collection
of sandals and high heels?
-Okay. Okay.
-And -- Yeah, like, wait.
-Oh, my goodness.
Yeah, 4, 5, 6.
-No, no, no.
I'm looking at the rows.
-You're counting.
You have the 4, 5, 6,
high heels, and sandals.
Give me a break.
You're talking about shoes,
because from the interview,
you were talking about shoes,
and now it's in your head.
-No, I wasn't.
-Yes, you were
talking about high heels
for the Mark Twain thing.
So let me tell you
something -- you lie!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Ding ]
-Oh!
You know, I've got to
tell you something.
I really pride myself
on being a good liar,
so I'm incredibly
upset right now.
-Oh, I thought you were
going to say impressed.
I thought you were going to
say impressed.
-No!
-Guys, what number
shall I choose?
[ Indistinct shouting ]
There is no 11.
3. Okay.
Somebody yelled "11."
There is no 11.
Thank you, though.
[ Straining ]
-Oh, it must be heavy.
Wow. That looks so, so heavy.
You poor thing.
Your arms are killing you.
Yeah.
-My arms are killing me.
Here we go here.
And that's a...
Abbondanza.
Okay.
-Yeah.
-I feel like I should just
tell you the truth,
because sometimes the truth is
funnier than fiction.
-Right, but this is called
"Box of Lies," just F.Y.I.
Anyway, carry on.
-Well, it's two contestants from
"The Masked Singer"
in a tiny hot tub
filled with Jell-O.
-Two contestants from what?
-"The Masked Singer,"
the show --
The mystery singers on Fox
with the giant bee heads
and alien heads.
-First of all, note to self --
I have to watch that show.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're missing out.
It's over already.
You missed it.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
-Let me tell you something.
I think that you --
I think you're
telling me the truth.
[ Drum roll ]
Oh, come on.
[ Buzzer ]
-This is the best game
I've ever played.
Ever!
I've never been this good.
-I hate this game!
-I'm usually terrible
at this game.
This is great!
-Can I go now?
-We're doing one more round.
This one is worth 10,000 points.
-Okay, you guys...
[ Indistinct shouting ]
Can -- Wait a minute.
Can everybody please
just speak once at a time?
-Yeah.
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-2? 2.
-So, here we go.
-Okay.
-I'm hot.
-I got to get to 2.
-You can't get me.
I'm hot, man! I'm hot!
Ow-wah!
Oh, it's really heavy.
Oh, my God. Oh, my goodness.
It's really so heavy.
Oh, look at how
exhausted you are.
Oh, my God.
-Actually, it's quite light.
-Oh, it is.
-Okay.
-Oh, it's light? Okay. Wow.
Now, I don't know if
that was a lie or true.
Okay. Okay.
How are you? Everything good?
-Are you familiar
with something...
-This is how you play the game?
Am I familiar with a closet?
Yes.
-Something called a paintbrush?
-Yes, of course.
-Okay.
And...
[ Laughs ]
And have you
ever braided your hair?
Or your wife's hair
or your daughter's hair?
-Yes.
-Okay, so, what this is
a paintbrush of hair
that's been braided with --
What do you call that thing?
A ponytail holder at the end.
-Like, a scrunchie?
-No, it's not.
I said it's a ponytail holder.
Come on. Let's go.
-What's a ponytail holder?
I've never even heard of that.
Why didn't you say,
"Are you familiar
with ponytail holders?"
I'm not.
-You are not.
-I am not.
I have no idea what that means.
A ponytail holder?
-Well, it's like a thinner thing
that's not a scrunchie.
-A rubber band?
A rubber band?
-No, a ponytail holder.
A rubber band is made of rubber
and can tear your hair.
This is a ponytail holder.
-Made of fabric.
-It's also --
There's paint on it and also...
[ Laughter ]
I love this game.
Can I come back
and play again tomorrow?
-This is unbelievable.
Okay. Gosh.
-By all means, take your time.
-I'm going to say...you lie.
-Whoo!
-Oh, it worked!
[ Dinging ]
Oh, come on!
I was like,
"That's too descriptive.
That's too good."
Julia Louis-Dreyfus, everybody!